well as you may have read barack obama
was all set to
host a party for himself worthy of an
ottoman sultan
on his spread on martha's vineyard 500
people invited hundreds of servants
possibly some writing elephants or
carrying his litter
now we have learned that in the face of
criticism the party has been quote
scaled back
but you know what hasn't been scaled
back barack obama's ambition or his
desire
for your money according to long-time
obama adviser valerie jarrett
you should still pay somehow she just
tweeted this
for barack obama's birthday gift i'm
asking you
to chip in six or sixty dollars to help
bring us the obama presidential center
to life in chicago is this the ugly face
of neoliberalism
that is a rhetorical question glenn
greenwald writes on sub stack he keeps
taps on the obama presidential center
and he joins us thank glenn thanks so
much for coming on
now barack obama's gotten very rich from
netflix
not sure what he's doing for them but he
certainly is rich um
why is he asking for more money
now
yeah i mean first of all i do think we
should stop and comment on the fact that
public officials when they leave power
routinely get not just rich but like
they turn into plutocrats like tycoons
and obviously that's not just obama by
the way knowing which of these
right yeah not just obama the clintons
tony blair
george bush all of them have become
extremely wealthy once they leave power
which i think is a big problem in a
democracy but leaving that to the side
the idea of presidential libraries
originally that didn't exist for like
150 years because the idea was
you're just a private citizen you go
serve in public office and then you go
back to private life you don't need like
a
a shrine to your existence and what
happened was it was born of good motives
franklin roosevelt knew he had gone
through all these historically momentous
events like the great depression in
world war ii when he said you know these
papers of mine don't belong to me they
belong to
the public and historians let's just
kind of create a library where
historians can go study for it
and over the years it became bigger and
bigger and bigger and what obama is
doing is unprecedented not only
is it so grandiose in size so much
bigger than anyone else's
it has four different buildings and 235
foot museum tower in his honor it's like
not even a roman emperor would do that
but he has also removed it from the
record keeping system which has always
been administered by the national
archives
that ensures that these papers belong to
the public the idea in the first place
they now belong to him and so to keep
control of it
he's raising money from people in the
middle of a
pandemic and a joblessness and eviction
crisis
right as he was planning a multi-million
dollar birthday bash
at his 12 million dollar estate which is
his second weekend home on martha's
vineyard
it is as you say the ethos of
neoliberalism leaders get rich at the
expense of everybody else
how long before we have mausoleums
within bombed bodies
of our leaders through which we file you
know we send school kids to file
respective you know respectfully and
kind of pay their respects
to the dear leaders of old
yeah and i mean you know i think a good
question as well is traditionally
the ruling class has been very reluctant
to be so flamboyant about their abuse of
power and their accumulation of wealth
because that can create a lot of
instability in the society when people
know
the extent to which they're being
exploited and abused they've generally
been more humble about it or tried to
hide it
but here's obama throwing this enormous
party stephen spielberg was coming pearl
jam was going to play
and then you have valerie jarrett his
lifelong age saying hey reach into your
pocket and give us money to build a
shrine
to obama at some point the question is
how long is the population going to
tolerate that
that's right at least televangelists
promise salvation
at least you get something out of it oh
it's so good glenn greenwald
great to see you tonight thank you good
to see you tucker
hey sean hannity here hey click here to
subscribe to fox news youtube page
and catch our hottest interviews and
most compelling analysis
you will not get it anywhere else